[Music]
she's here right here in Ramsey
solutions lobby Sara's weather hey Sarah
how are you so much better than I
deserve Dave thank you well done well
done where are you from College Station
Texas good how much you pay off
just under $33,000 love it how long did
that take you three years and two months
okay range of income during that time
for most of it I was only making $26,000
a year as a newspaper reporter towards
the end thirty five thousand and then in
the last month I went up to 42 Wow I
also had a little side business where I
made eleven thousand last year okay good
for you what was your strategy YouTube
actually I'm one of the crazy people on
YouTube documenting their debt free
journeys my channels budget girl I saw
the budget girl thing pop up a while ago
yeah fun fun so and YouTube's making me
a lot of money then it is good yeah it's
pretty amazing actually I just talked
about getting out of debt and following
your plan and it's the day-to-day where
you provide the framework and I'm
following it and so many people are
there they want encouragement they want
accountability and we're on there every
single day rooting for each other yeah
and you're inspiring people so I'm glad
you're making some money good for you
well done good good good what kind of
debt was the thirty three thousand all
student loans though I do have to admit
that I took out a little extra to live
on during college because I was a
special kind of idiot
why a to go so what's your degree in
in-school communications and journalism
okay cool so your main gig is newspaper
reporter well for most of my debt free
journey I was just at the very end I
started working at Texas A&M as a
communication specialist oh is that
where you graduated from no I am
actually a graduate of Mississippi
University for women gotcha okay very
cool well good so you're officially an
Aggie now I am
big time okay good for you well done
this is quite a journey here I mean
three years and two months you've been
at this making $26,000 when you started
and all the way up to now making forty
two side gig side hustle you've done it
all well done pizzas I a little bit of
horse trading I did secret shopping I
did dog training even though I wasn't
qualified babysitting anything I could I
was so mad at that debt dog training
even though I'm not calling make the dog
behave so it counts right so how did you
start this journey well I was working at
a newspaper out of college and I got
laid off and I hadn't been paying on my
student loans in a couple of years since
I had gotten out cuz I didn't think that
I made enough the government said I
didn't have to pay and I didn't realize
that my homes had shut up like five
grand since I graduated and I was so
scared Dave I didn't know how it's gonna
make rent I didn't know how I was gonna
eat and I decided then and there I'd
already heard of you
that once I got a new job that I was
never gonna be that scared again I was
going to get out of that debt good for
you good for you so young single lady
make it a six grand yeah you it is scary
it was terrifying now and and so you got
after it then that fear will propel you
it'll move you man I mean some of the
best work I've ever done is when I was
scared out of my mind it's so very good
job fun so you've been telling people on
YouTube of obviously but I'm gonna ask
you again what is the secret what did
you do what's the secret sauce what did
you do to get out of that how do you
tell people what do you tell people and
they say how'd you do that
three three main components the first is
a budget and it's this magical thing
where if you make a plan for your money
and then you actually follow that plan
your money does what you want it to do
which is so common sense
I never thought of it and like you say
all the time making the person in the
mirror mind you and all of a sudden
everything's happening the second is to
have some sort of accountability I
started the YouTube channel because I
knew that my friends and family would
get so sick of me talking about it all
the time and I knew if I was going to be
my main focus that's all I was going to
want to talk about and so there are
thousands and hundreds of thousands of
people online on Instagram on YouTube on
Facebook they're all these communities
out there most are dedicated to you of
people just rooting each other on in the
day to day and if you need motivation it
is there there are people there who
believe the same thing you do that will
prop you up some of your Posse with you
I did these are my friends from college
and they were there with me when I was
getting into debt and they supported me
while I was getting out of debt and
they're here to celebrate with me that's
part of the cheerleading in the things
what's the third one the third is to
have kind of little rewards set up along
the way I went scorched-earth Dave I
didn't buy any clothes for three years I
didn't buy any home decor I didn't go
out to eat so for every $5,000 I paid
off I gave myself about fifty dollars to
do something nice with to kind of mark
the milestones along the way and remind
me to keep pushing for 50 whole dollars
yeah Wow well at the halfway mark I
spent like 200 and so if I wanted
something I could say if I still want it
when I pay off another five thousand
dollars of the debt that'll be my reward
and it spurred me on like crazy so that
was that was one little secret of mine
was to mark the milestones and really
look forward to those I bought this
little ring when I only had ten thousand
dollars yet it was like a thirty dollar
purchase but every time I wear it it
reminds me that I'm winning and that I'm
working towards something Wow
you're powerful very well done very well
done I love it so what was the the most
encouraging thing that came from your
you two double YouTube audience what
that somebody said to you in the
comments or something you got back when
you went wow I'm gonna that that that
lifted me up
people tell me that one that they
learned about you through my channel or
two that they figured out that they knew
about you but they didn't see how they
could do it before I was showing my
actual budget every month of what I made
and where I put it and how much I was
putting the debt because people kept
telling me I was crazy to do it at
$26,000 a year but I was showing my
budget every single month saying this is
how much that I have this is where all
my money is going and this is how much
I'm paying off and so they're
encouraging me and celebrating with me
and so many of them as they were paying
off debt they were saying like you
showed me that I could do it or you gave
me you know inspiration to keep going
and if you can do it at $26,000 then I
can do it at $80,000 or whatever they
had so that was so how much of a breeze
is it to live on 42 now I feel so rich
that's gonna sound so weird but I yeah
I'm already 75 percent funded of bs3
it's amazing to have my money my own
again and I was so used to living on
such a small percentage of my income it
was like less than 50% I was I was you
know just doing anything I could to cut
an extra corner you know aside from like
being unethical but I don't think it's
an accident that most people's income
goes up while they're doing this in your
case I think it's particularly
interesting the way that I mean your
income has doubled actually almost I
mean this is so impressive so impressive
very very very well known what was the
hardest part for you telling myself no
every day for a long time but every time
I told myself no I said because you're
going after something more important and
I actually wasn't worth it so worth it
if I had followed the government's
payoff plan I would be over 40 before I
paid off my loans I turned 30 on Tuesday
I have the rest of my life to do what I
want with my money to be fear
financially I'm gonna retire a
millionaire because I started this
program you are you definitely are
there's an any question about that I'm
inspired they're delightful wonderful is
this fun well we've definitely got the
copy of the book to help you Chris
Hogan's a retire inspire that is the
next chapter in your story I'm talking
to a future millionaire right here
there's no doubt in anybody's mind
watching this or listening to it that
that's the case
very well done all right count it down
let's hear your debt free scream all
right thank you so much Dave's three two
one
well done this is the Dave Ramsey show